[Music]
hey I'm crash and we're here on the set
of daddy's home - but this time we see
Mark Wahlberg and Will Ferrell's
character dealing with bear dad played
by Mel Gibson and John list oh you guys
have become quite the duo this is your
third movie together I want to know what
is the best part about working like each
other oh my stomach hurts a lot at the
end of the day for laughing so much for
oh that's the only downside over man
it's a lot of fun
do you have an absolute great time keeps
getting better and better than our third
movie together now we have an instant
shorthand we can kind of just share look
and know what the other ones thinking
that's what's so fun about this one
daddy Tom - now you guys bring your
dad's involved with you guys have some
amazing dad to be able to have a guy
like Mel playing a dusty dad find a guy
was that cool and that like we even
though he can be a bit of a ballbuster
issues when I was it was the perfect
choice John plays my father were very
emotionally secure with each other kind
of overshare not afraid to kiss the
public yeah it was kind of reveal that
we aren't exactly the way we seem to be
on the outside so this time you guys
come around in your plane dusty and Brad
dad how is the relationships between
will and marking you guys it's a
wonderful role grandad we're both
granddad you know and what they say is
true you get all the joy of fatherhood
and none of the responsibilities yeah
Brad and Dawn that's our father and some
knowledge
it's very nurturing loving others I'm
really there's hurt and dusty which is
very competitive
it's combative it a little more well
dysfunctional yeah so you mix us all
together over Christmas and all hell
breaks loose especially where we're
filming in this huge I'm sure you guys
Cara Lee sees that there's like dead
animals all over the place there's a
modicum of tasteful taxidermy I mean you
can see there's goats and polar bears
all over yeah so it seems like it's
gonna get very very interesting possible
it is yes you're gonna have some gunplay
I gotta ask you guys what has been like
the best fatherly advice you've ever
received she looked at me and said you
know I look back on my entire life and
it had seemed like and at the end it's
going to seem like an instant so don't
screw it up there's only a finite time
you have with your kids well there and
to not waste that oh well thank you guys
for bringing me out here I really
appreciate from thank you take care xx
Piper song
[Music]
you